this graph from last december shows the
proportion of people who had coveted
antibodies either from prior infection
vaccination or both based on blood donor
surveys as you can see about 94 of
people 16 and older had some protection
against cobit but around the same time
at the end of december there was a huge
spike going into the new year and that
data hints at why re-infections will
become a part of our new normal so
how is it that so many people had
protection against covet but still
somehow managed to get infected recent
estimates suggest that somewhere between
10 and 15 percent of the cases we're
seeing are actually re-infections and
some experts think that figure will
continue to climb the rates of
breakthrough infections which happen
after vaccination have also increased
there are two main reasons for that
first as we've learned from our ongoing
covet coverage antibodies wane with time
the lower your antibody levels are the
less protected you tend to be if we look
closely at the first chart that i showed
you it says that nearly everyone 16 and
over in the u.s had antibodies but it
doesn't specify at what level the second
reason we're likely to continue to see
re-infections is that our antibodies
don't adapt as quickly as the virus does
so over time the virus becomes better at
evading the antibodies we have worked so
hard to build up that's what happened
with omicron the surgeon cases which you
can see in this graph coincided with the
arrival of the variant the antibodies we
had weren't as good at recognizing the
virus so the chance of free infection
was higher as this study showed that's
why we kept hearing so much about this
omicron variant has shown a surprising
ability to break through our defenses
some are wondering if people can get
re-infected research from earlier this
year showed that boosters increased
antibody levels and that helped with
protection against omicron why well it's
a numbers game even if antibodies become
less effective it's not like they lose
the capacity to block the virus from
infecting your cells altogether so
having more can balance out some of that
loss and effectiveness to further
counteract that loss companies are also
working to tailor their vaccines to more
recent variants or even to multiple ones
but for now how often we'll need
boosters is still tbd we went over a lot
of this in our booster video so if
you're interested in learning more check
that out public health experts say that
for the foreseeable future boosters will
be critical for keeping up our immunity
against covet at a population level what
happens at a population level is also
really important for what happens to you
the higher the rates of covet cases the
more virus you'll encounter and that
means that in high density cities like
new york where people are crowded
together in small spaces the likelihood
of getting infected is much higher
especially if your antibodies are
declining the good news chances are that
if you got coveted after getting
vaccinated your case will be on the
milder side data from washington state
in may for instance showed that 12 to 34
year olds who were unvaccinated were
four times more likely to end up in the
hospital than people who were vaccinated
by keeping people out of the hospital
and from dying public health experts say
that the vaccines are still giving us a
leg up against the virus and it's that
chaos of mass hospitalizations that
contributed heavily to the disruptions
we all experienced early on in the
pandemic the cdc recently estimated that
about 60 percent of people have had
covet as more people get exposed and
vaccinated covet will become less
disruptive because our immune system
would have learned to recognize it and
attack it and we're actually already
starting to see that happen as omicron
cases spike again there seems to be
limited impacts so far at least here in
the u.s we've covered covet a lot and it
has been a really long journey but i'm
happy to say that we're no longer
defenseless against covet we've built up
some level of immunity so even if
reinfections become more common it's
unlikely to be all doom and gloom from
here on out that gives us signs of hope
that the worst is behind us
[Music]